in order
for traffic Council of Chris boys
foreign
good evening councilors ladies and
gentlemen and I welcome you to this
meeting of the council
um once again I'm afraid that my
chaplain is called away for duties his
wife is still unwell uh Reverend Richard
Sherrod so I'm going to say a few words
this time but this time from scripture
actually
um
I don't know if you will be familiar
with the one Thessalonians chapter five
but you'll see perhaps why I've chosen
it is quite short I'm starting at verse
15. see that none render to any man evil
for evil
but ever follow that which is good both
to one another and to all men Rejoice
Evermore
pray without ceasing in everything give
thanks for this is the will of God in
Christ Jesus concerning you quench not
the spirit despise not prophesies prove
all things hold fast that which is good
abstain from all appearance of evil amen
thank you
yes
a move to apologies and I have received
apologies of absence from counselors
Bennett
Western Brophy chulkin Gilbert Myers
whitsam and Wright can I ask if anyone
is aware of any other apologies
foreign
Morgan was on his way from Liverpool
are there any other apologies sorry
Council of Western Council Dr Serena
Carr got Dr Serena Carr thank you
any further apologies
no in which case voting and broadcast
information
we continue with a hybrid system in the
chamber this evening for microphones and
for streaming the microphones work by
pressing the bar on and off up to a
maximum of three at one time however we
will still awaiting full installation
before we can use the voting system
until then I will ask for a show of
hands should a vote be necessary this
evening
the meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
YouTube channel the whole of the meeting
will be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items and this
activity promotes Democratic engagement
in accordance with section 100 a
brackets nine close brackets of the
Local Government Act 1972 thank you
item one minutes the first item is there
for the minutes and I move that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 23rd
of November 2022 be taken as read and
signed as a correct record is this
seconded seconded map thank you leader
all in favor
thank you item two announcements does
the leader of the council wish to make
any announcements this evening
I have no announcements to make mayor
thank you thank you councilor Ross
leader do the chairs of the scrutiny
committees have anything to announce on
behalf of their committees councilor
Acton
thank you Mr Mayor
um I just wanted to mention about the
field of trust
and many of you will recall the council
referred a motion at a meeting last year
which asks scrutiny to look into the
possibility of placing all our parks and
Open Spaces being placed into a field of
trust protection
in light of that scrutiny received a
report and discussed the issues and
concluded it would be an expense it
would be an expense for the council as
we would need to employ more staff in
the existing team to implement all the
156 sites that we have in the Buddha
there are already various protections on
these sites and some of the sites have
field of trust protection and some are
actually gaining that protection over
the next few months
in light of that scrutiny committee felt
there was no need to change our existing
policy regarding the protection of our
precious parks and land thank you very
much Mr Smith
thank you councilor Acton uh councilor
wetton
thank you Mr Mayor just to
um by way of a further in mind are to
remind members that the health scooting
Tuscan finish
group doing a project access to GPS that
we are seeking all members to be
involved with that by getting five
surveys
completed from their local
Ward residents people who who used GPS
in within Trafford
um
by getting a quantity from each member
of the council we get a Borough wide
coverage we've extended the deadline
recently to the beginning of February
and I just would urge everybody to to
get on board please it's a quicker job
than maybe it sounds to some
and it will be very helpful to get that
cross-section of information to us for
this particular project thank you thank
you councilor and I would Echo that if
members haven't yet actually picked up
their five questionnaires from their
pigeon holes they will be there in a
brown envelope for you moving on
councilor Denise Weston
nothing to report at the moment Mr Mayor
thank you councilor Weston item three
questions
writing through his questions on members
have submitted 10 questions for this
meeting which have been listed on the
council website for members of the
public to view
on the basis that I've asked for
responses to be sent to the questioners
and both be published and circulated
around the chamber I will take both the
question and response as read and move
on to the supplementary in each case
where a response hasn't yet been
provided we will have to deal with those
as usual
supplementary questions shall be put and
answered without discussion and we will
now take the questions in the order in
which they were received
the first question please is from
councilor Jed Carter
thank you Matt do I take it that I don't
need to read the question I just take it
was given you I think this is one that
is this one that we haven't had a
response so it is one where the the
question needs to be read
I was told that there were three that
had not been answered but now we've had
a very late uh response so yes the
answer your question is yes you can take
it that the question has been seen has
been answered and I will now ask you
whether you have a supplementary
question
right thank you
question two is from councilor G
uh thank you I do have a supplementary
questions
sorry so yes the answer the initial
answer has been circulated in the answer
to my question which I was about to ask
do you have a supplementary you do
please go ahead thank you uh thank you
for the answers uh the important award I
have received the many complaints about
three Works undertaken by utility
providers what is it residents have also
expressed concerns regarding
coordination between utility companies
on occasions a highway has been
reinstated following Street Works only
for it to be dug up again soon after on
behalf of another utility companies can
executive members tell me what steps the
council can undertake to ensure between
coordinations to ensure better
coordinations between the companies and
ensure taxpayers money can be spent
fairly and efficiently
thank you Council the Z and I'd ask
councilor wed out head to respond to
that supplementary question thank you
thank you Mariner Council uh
supplementary question first of all
obviously uh comment on your last Point
first in relation to that as these
utility companies there are no public
money involved in it is purely private
companies so there's actually no cost to
the public purse in that uh I'm aware of
one complaint relating to Bolden Ward
and I believe that you had a
satisfactory answer to that Earl in the
air it was explained to actually how
that worked I'm not aware of there is
coordination as you as you will remember
certain prime minister many years ago in
the 80s actually set free reign on the
utilities and actually uh but Latin do
what they wanted when they wanted and at
that point the local authorities had no
say on it thankfully we now have a GM
wraps as we call it and there is a
website which I've sent to members on
many occasions GM Road works if you look
that size up there that details all the
information required on on every Works
in in the whole of the connotation you
zoom down into a map it shows you who
the company is what they're doing the
start day end date and also lists of
information as well like a contact
telephone number for his contact each of
these is a little roadworks sign and
it's red Amber green denoting the level
of activity a green is very basic one is
from the street corner to a red one
which could be multi-way signals and all
information is there and that's been
well publicized I will send you the link
again after I I'll send you a meeting
I've got the next question as well as
well to do it shortly uh but it's a very
useful website you will find that but
generally yes there is coordination
every utility company it has to ask for
permission which is part of the permit
system and then if there are problems
with it they can be looked at members
can report problems with them and they
are inspected uh I'm not discourse the
companies any of that is a particular
problem I should say actually all the
utilities works are inspected at the end
of the works when they're completed and
a fair percentage of them are inspected
during the works as well they look
problematic or there are non-particular
problem companies that deal with so
there's a full regime in place in
Greater Manchester now which they don't
have uh in all areas of the country and
I think it's a good example to work have
you had problems I know you're actually
aware of the details of who to contact
on this as well so hopefully that
addresses your question thank you
thank you councilor ad said question
three is the first of two from councilor
Wilton
I believe is this one that has been
answered initially
and
do you have a supplementary question
thank you
to informing future Council policy in
this area
sorry a councilor ad said to respond
again to that one thank you ma'am thank
you for your supplementary question
Council Welton obviously welcome all
comments uh I know she had a full
explanation uh on it if he clicked on
the link for one uh actually on the uh
on the reply that was sent to you that
explains to you the uh this work that we
do in in heavy weather particular
obviously the weather we read recently
was fairly likely in most areas if it
wasn't not as much of an issue obviously
appreciate that in some locations there
can be problems and these are all aware
of and where I think you put in one
particular location for you to be looked
at and I believe that is being looked at
as we speak in that sense hopefully
you'll get response to that in due
course if you don't please do cop them
in obviously we've got particular
concerns about it that then obviously do
let us know in general terms obviously
uh the council has scrutiny committee
and obviously they can review all sorts
of services in that sense and that's
what if the scrutiny committee think
it's a good idea so I personally think
that would be potentially a good idea
but obviously that's up to the scrutiny
committees who actually decide those
options of our process in place review
that and I'd welcome anything like that
to look at and I think we need an
in-depth way to look it would be a way
forward but obviously we've done at the
request of scrutiny with that obviously
we do any concerns obviously uh I know
you're quite able to copy Us in with
things and we're always welcome I know
we do monitor for reply so hope that
addressed your concerns thank you
councilor Welton
thank you councilor ads head councilor
Welton the second of your questions
please uh I gather this has been
answered initially yes
in which case do you have a
supplementary question
thank you
Council contribute to her many years of
service would be a commitment to
implement the actions set out in the
greater Manchester active travel Public
Health Manifesto
thank you thank you councilor Welton
councilor Williams to respond to that
supplementary question thank you
thank you chair and thank you um
councilor welcome for your supplementary
question
um I agree certainly with the spirit of
what you're asking there and there are
several options recommended in the
manifesto that link to the work Trafford
is already delivering on active travel
in partnership with Trump and spoke the
greater Manchester and the greater
Manchester combined Authority Trafford
is presently Consulting on its walking
wheeling and cycling strategy which
identifies the approach that the council
will be undertaking linked to the GM
transport strategy 2040.
Trafford is actively progressing several
schemes and initiatives about which I'll
be happy to provide you with a very
brief update in respective low traffic
neighborhoods homestein has been
identified as an area that would benefit
from a range of measures to support
active travel and is being progressed
with funding by transport for greater
Manchester
or the localities have been introduced
including Longford Park and a public
consultation and scoping exercise has
been completed in in respect of the
Walton Road estate in sale
in respect of 20 mile an hour zones and
safer streets there are many requested
such measures and Trafford can progress
several 20 mile an hour streets in areas
and are focusing in and around schools I
know that you're aware counselor that
there is a specific funding
consideration relating to that work and
I would suggest that more funding is
needed to accelerate that program in
respective safer pedestrian areas all
new public ground development work has
been designed in line with transport for
greater Manchester streets for all
strategy and design guide we've been
working collaboratively with tfgm to
ensure transport trafford's review of
its own design guide the lines with the
street swirl principles to ensure future
developments are safe for pedestrians
respect to parking enforcement this is
particularly difficult particularly
difficult sorry to tackle as it requires
significant resource
additionally there were competing
demands for parking in many of our
streets and that's a situation which is
not unique to Trafford obstruction of
the highway is also police function to
enforce having a zero parking policy on
Pavements will potentially cause issues
with access to emergency vehicles in
some of our older and narrower streets
that were not designed for the number of
cars that are presently being used for
households in particularly bad areas we
do look to introduce yellow lines to
protect Junctions and streets of High
football government guidance is still
awaited on this however with the
ambition to move to a 50 50 modal shift
there should be a reduction in car
ownership in the media to longer term
that will allow enforcement to be
undertaken with reduced consequences as
described subjects to resources being
available
you'll also be aware counselor if
changes in the council's approach to
enforcement as approved at the meeting
of executive committee earlier this week
in respect of better access to cycling
and walking opportunities the reciprocal
schemes now reaching detailed design and
delivery stage across Trafford which are
linked to the active travel funding of
20 million pounds that is currently
allocated to the council
these schemes are offering better access
to cycling and walking
these are being delivered in
collaboration with transport for greater
Manchester and there's a large pipeline
of areas that Trafford will progress in
the median to longer term
progression will however be subject to
further funding being delivered from
active travel England so I hope
counselor
um as I said you you appreciate that we
do very much agree with the spirit of
your question
um thank you thank you
thank you councilor Williams the next
question is counts with councilor
Maitland and I understand the answer has
been given to the initial question is
that correct yes thank you mayor in
which case do you have a supplementary
question no satisfactory answer has been
received and no supplementary questions
thank you uh moving on to question six
then councilor Walsh uh question which I
believe has not yet been answered could
uh has been circulated you want to put
the question and then we'll hear the
answers right thank you councilor Walsh
foreign
excuse me many residents have approached
me
asking what the council is doing to to
support the community in these difficult
times
can I ask the executive member for
culture Leisure and strategic
Partnerships to explain what her
department is doing to support residents
around the cost of living crisis thank
you councilor Walsh and please go
counselor Harding respond to the
question thank you
this afternoon
[Music]
sorry to interrupt can I just ask has
the members of a chamber had that
response by email or tonight apparently
not I'm afraid councilor hargan off you
go thank you
I'm very pleased to say it was actually
um
quite quick Off the Mark really when we
realized that people were going to be
struggling
the cost of living crisis so some of the
things that we're doing we have traffic
assists which is our own
I'm sorry going on here
um our own in-house service providing
financial and Welfare
um assistance to help provide food
Furniture white goods and extra support
with fuel Bills free School meals
supporting children and young people
citizens advice Trafford we have a great
relationship and they provide support to
all of the community hubs welfare rights
Services providing tailored support to
access benefits and budget support
advisors as I've just said are at the
community hubs the living room projects
I'm really pleased to say that a lot of
the community providers have stepped up
and provided a warm space for many of
our residents and they'll be available
right through until March so they're
often providing a warm space Wi-Fi hot
food and drink and Company really for
those people that are socially isolated
the winter well-being packs 3 000 were
packed and distributed to Residents with
blankets hot water bottles hats gloves
and information about local services
the real living wage additional payments
for 320 staff on the lowest pay bans
working in our schools and across the
council being uplifted to the real
living wage energy works offering free
advice and the money advice referral to
developed to boost household income and
access relevant support there's been a
big campaign across greater Manchester
about the pension credit and here in
Trafford we've done a big campaign on
that help with school uniform and we
have launched the Trafford poverty truth
commission which has been a brilliant
piece of work bringing together
community and Civic Commissioners so we
really hear the true story of what it's
like to live with poverty in Trafford
and some of those recommendations are
going to be brought forward in March
uh we're working closely with Partners
who have helped us to respond such as
Trafford Housing Trust and to help the
winter support fund for residents and I
have to say that whilst I applaud This
brilliant work and I really really do
um this labor Administration can never
settle for food banks and living rooms
to be an accepted part of our society
the work we're doing as part of the
poverty truth commission and the poverty
Action Group will set out bold plans for
the future to strive to eradicate
poverty which of course is one of our
corporate priorities thank you councilor
Walsh thank you councilor Harding and
councilor Walsh do you have a
supplementary question no thank you
chair right thank you
question seven
um I think I'm right question seven uh
as with councilor Duncan have you had a
response to your first question
yes I have yes in which case do you have
a supplementary question yes I do thank
you
um
right I'd like to thank the member for
his response
the letter from the Secretary of State
requested a full response to his letter
regarding housing standards
by the 27th of January 2023
will the response will the response be
shared with members and more widely to
Trafford citizens
last year was pleased to see central
government awarded an additional 975
000 pounds towards the Regeneration of
sail west estate however
The Damp and mold issues in many
apartments still exist
existing residents needs must be dealt
with
and on several visits to sell West
residents I have witnessed firsthand
difficult conditions families are living
in
that is all very well smiling on glossy
brochures and in the Press promoting the
new builds
however action is needed now to promote
properties that pose dangers to health
so will you please work with us to
promote the needs of existing residents
thank you thank you for your
supplementary question uh councilor
Duncan in the absence of councilor
Wright can I ask councilor Ross a leader
to respond to that supplementary
question
thank you I am aware of the letter and I
know it will be submitted by the 27th of
January and I will certainly come back
to you with whether we can we can
publish the uh the letter itself I just
need to check the uh the state of play
with officers I know as part of that
letter though we will be asking
government for more resource because
there's only so much we can do with a
small team look at enforcement you raise
an incredibly important point and we've
seen the tragic incidents elsewhere in
in Greater Manchester it is something we
desperately want to avoid so thank you
for raising it I will take that away we
will get an answer back to you uh soon
but I know as part of that letter we do
ask for more resource so that we can put
greater enforcement in and inspect
inadequate properties thank you Matt
thank you leader councilor Ross the
question eight is with councilor Holden
I'm assuming I think you've had your
first response in which case do you have
a supplementary question
thank you Mr Mayor
sorry one small query
I have received a very well crafted and
very comprehensive response to my
question
but I'm not sure that anyone else has
all right okay I apologize
as this response gone to anyone else
I've got somebody whispering in my left
ear suggesting that it may well not have
done in which case given the question
having been circulated can I ask
councilor ad said to respond to the
initial question thank you okay
understanding was in the first place
obviously it was sent over to office and
I understand I was copied into a message
from Sarah seller to Ian Cocker which
indicated the full response has been
sent earlier in the week so I'm happy to
read it out but it was actually all sent
out so I personally took to send it this
afternoon to councilor Holden because
I'm I'm not well obviously he may not
have seen it otherwise but I don't know
I mean I'm happy to read it out if you
if I'd be grateful if you could go ahead
and just read the in your the in the
response to the first question and we'll
move on then to any supplementary maybe
forthcoming thank you
like
traffic Council currently operates and
from 71 Crossing sites across the
borough all our current sites have been
categorized using the national guidance
published by boat safety Great Britain
the provision of safe Crossing staff is
not a statutory Duty for councils
however we recognize that they make a
valuable contribution towards pupils
safe and sustainable travel to schools
there are four categories of SCP site as
defined by the guidance category p
a SCP is Justified at the site though
it's recommended that a signal control
Crossing is installed instead
category a and SCP is Justified at the
site category b a sap site is not
initially Justified what further factors
such as proximities Crossing to
Junctions and the age of the children
using the crossing may be considered and
may potentially move the point into
category a
category C nor justification for an SCP
on a successional circumstances exist
Trafford has 66 category a Crossings I.E
that a SCP is Justified there were five
are category B but have additional
traffic Road Junction issues the
guidance also states that there is a
fully automatic traffic signal
well so where where there is a orthod
automatic drive signal Crossing there is
no need to have a staff Crossing unless
there is exceptional circumstances we
currently have 12
school crossing Patrol vacancies that we
have not managed to recruit to despite
continuing to run recruitment campaigns
we're also seeking to recruit mobile
staff to enable us to cover staff that
are unavailable due to sickness absence
our objective is to have full staff
complement to ensure we can cover all 71
of air staffed Crossings as it is never
difficult to move stuff from one
Crossing to another when we do not have
adequate staff in conjunction with road
safety a transport for greater
Manchester survey is to be commissioned
on a small number of suitable Crossings
to assess the possibility of placing
automatic signal Crossings to mitigate
the need for school crossing Patrol
thank you councilor ad said for what
appeared to be a comprehensive First
Response councilor Holden do you have a
supplementary question
yes Mr Mayor you can now see why I began
this session by saying it was a
comprehensive and detailed response
um however I think my
supplementary still stands up and if
you'll excuse me I hate reading stuff
and I'm going to read this supplementary
so that we know what what I'm asking
want additional methods have the council
put in place since 2018
to improve Recruitment and thereby
decrease the vacancies and what
interventions such as additional light
control Crossings have been installed
thank you Council Holden the answer to
that question is with councilor ad set
again
Council Holden for a supplementary
obviously uh there is ongoing
advertisement I'm sure if you need more
information up we can get that for you
obviously I'm seeing this quite regular
uh I think the biggest problem is and
it's not just since 2018 it's probably
for a long long time though certainly
well into your Administration a long
long time ago that we've had with
problems recruiting and particularly in
certain parts of the world it's a
long-standing problem uh and it is one
that is uh quite hard to actually
achieve in some cases it does need to be
a growing problem I don't know I mean
one of my thoughts that I'd will be
mentioning to officer soon and uh will
be to actually ask about the problem why
do I I know it's working with wider than
traffic but actually how wide it is
across the connotation and indeed
perhaps Countrywide they do seem to be
these days people less willing to
actually take it on in the same way they
did many years ago probably for a whole
variety of reasons so I'm just not quite
clear in that sense to actually uh
actually uh what all the solutions I
don't have the solutions to that in that
sense what if you have any suggestions
actually how we can improve advertising
and so forth please do put them in I
have actually asked other questions
previously about other ways the
potentially doing it and some of those
have actually been looked at already and
and they haven't really been suitable in
that censorship but I think I'm open to
all our suggestion please do put it in
in terms of uh of programs to install
Crossings you've actually seen the
response there that's a number of them
are now been examined through tfgm and
each year that all sites are put there
are requests for all sorts of things for
the capital program and indeed I know
many councils do put these requests in
and these are considered and the clear
criteria actually how we can implement
it and obviously I know that sites one
of the my contributions to that was
particularly so so that where there is a
particular request and there's a school
in the vicinity that they do get higher
points and that will because a whole
range of schemes so it does as such
should give privacy more to schools that
as against other sorts of facilities so
I think well I'll just look at this
obviously if you've got particular
policy man do putting them in and there
are ways to cross it obviously big
Junctions themselves so they're
expensive these days so we don't put
them in directly ourselves it's done
through transport through very much
important bids for government schemes
and we're into bidding wars with all
authorities then like we have seen
recently with other particular problems
so they can cost usually between 50 000
up to if it's a full set of traffic
signals it can cost uh 150 000 or a
quarter of a million one case I saw one
recently so they're not cheap for for
the for uh if you need to put in a whole
new set of signals to accommodate
procession phases in them so uh what
isn't just simple of changing some
lights and so forth it can be that
expensive so obviously there are ways
around this we're happy to look at those
particular things and every location
will bring its own challenges and
different ways of doing things we cannot
say there's one simple solution that
will solve all these problems it's down
to location age of children Junction
layout age and everything like that so
there's lots of ways you can do things
obviously and if you've got particular
things in question do put them in do uh
and request and do coffee mean thank you
thank you councilor that's head question
nine is with councilor Axford
um have you had a response I'm just
double checking all the time you have
had the first response do you have a
supplementary question no I don't have
any supplementary questions I'm
delighted the response right thank you
so the response has been received and
that's passed on from there so final
question question 10 is with councilor
new grosh
um have you had a response or you have
do you have a supplementary I do you do
thank you we'll hear it thank you well
can I thank the exec member for that
answer I am however generally
disappointed that Council right was
unable to suppliers with an answer to
the number of long-term homes brought
back into use when I asked two years ago
the answer was just two I had been
hoping to need both hands to count our
progress to date
so my question I'm no tea is not there
so to exact member if Building Homes and
new office space on Greenbelt is not a
blight as counselor Wright asserts but
in fact a benefit to the local community
why has William Rowe been placed in a
field of trust instead of those
residents sharing in the claimed
benefits
thank you the councilor new gross and in
the absence of Council of right I
understand the answers to be given by
councilor Ross leader
thank you mayor without going into the
intricacies of places for everyone
um I'd just like to restate what
councilor Wright has put in the written
answer
um we we have a housing shortage there
are people desperate for housing in this
Borough there are people that have been
waiting a long time for housing in this
Borough there are people living with
their families waiting to move into
somewhere we have to look at places to
build houses and obviously timpley wedge
is one of those aspects that we've
looked at over the long term so we do
make no apology for looking at
increasing house building it is a big
priority for this Administration and it
will continue to be a big priority for
this Administration as we're building
the number of affordable houses we can't
go on as we are
it's we we don't we we have a desperate
shortage of Housing and so we are going
to keep going with our proposals and
hope in the longer term that Trafford
becomes a more affordable place for
people to live to raise their families
and to call home
thank you uh councilor Ross
that concludes the questions and we move
to item four petition save ortingham
Town Hall item four is a petition to
save ortingham Town Hall which earlier
this afternoon stood at 1
731 signatures in accordance with the
council's petition scheme the lead
petitioner is allowed to speak to the
petition for five minutes and we have
Trevor stone with us this evening who
will introduce the petition following
their introduction the petition will be
debated by Council for a maximum of 15
minutes as is the agreed practice for
petitions at council speeches are
normally limited to one member from each
of the groups and since there is only 15
minutes allowed for the debate each
group will be allocated three minutes
and 45 seconds following those debate
the leader of the council will then
summarize the council's response if
Council can censor the arrangements I
hope you will
I'll take that as a yes I will now
invite Trevor Stone to introduce the
petition thank you
thank you so Mr mayor councilor ladies
and gentlemen I'm here this evening to
present the community's case for saving
Autumn town hall for the use of the
community
it is disappointing I have to be here
but our dealings with the council have
not been easy
the town hall has served
could someone just double check
that the microphone is on and is a
suitable volume
foreign
we appear to have plan B
in which case as they say could you you
allowed can start start again if you
would thank you all right thank you Mr
Mayor
um I'm here this evening is that better
okay good I'm here this evening to
present the community's case for saving
Altrincham town hall for the use of the
community
it is disappointing I have to be here
that our dealings with the council have
not been easy
the town hall has served the community
well for the past 120 years and was
listed as an asset of community value in
2016.
we submitted to the council an
application to renew this for a further
five years in January 21. it took 12
months for this to be processed it
should have been done within 88 days
the return deadline for initial
expressions of interest in taking on a
lease of the Town Hall was actually 18
days before the ACV was finally Affirmed
we submitted ours and then had
productive discussions with local
businesses who could help us and also
with representatives of both Stratford
public hall and George Carnell
a second dii invitation was received on
the 7th of May
no proper explanation of the process and
its meaning was given to us and we were
not told anything to suggest it was to
be our final bid
we submitted reoa on the 26th of August
which showed we could fund the initial
cost of running the town hall from its
current level of income though we were
confident this could quickly be
increased with Beckham better marketing
of the facilities
Nothing Was Heard until the 10th of
November when we were asked to attend a
teams meeting the next day for a
catch-up
we were shocked shocked to quickly be
told right let's cut to the chase we
will not be proceeding any further with
your proposal
we were offered no explanation as to why
and in answer to where we might go once
the town hall was lost we were given
completely unrealistic suggestions it
was clear there could be no sensible
discussion and the meeting ended
after taking advice and seeking opinions
from other community groups and
counselors it was decided to set up the
petition which quickly attracted The
public's attention
on the 16th of January however we were
again shocked when we received an email
stating that of the 1252 signatures at
that time only 41 were valid which was
insufficient for the petition to be
heard by Council
it was obvious this just couldn't be the
case there was either a bug in the
system or its verification process was
unfit for purpose
the council did relent on this so I am
here now though no apology was given
in summary the whole process has been
shambolic and we've been made to feel
unfairly treated
the council has met its legal
obligations but it has not met the
spirit of them
we want to work with you not against you
to find a mutually agreeable solution
we know you have budgeting issues I
might say that I do too because my wife
home came home with a New Dress last
week
and we do understand the attraction to
you of a commercial company's bid we
obviously cannot compete with that
financially but we can remove from you
the liability of running and maintaining
the building
we would do this via a community
interest company and with our passion
for the building and its Heritage you
know we would do this properly
the town hall is perfectly located for
Access being in the heart of the old
Marketplace Conservation Area just
across the road from The Market Hall it
was the local seat of government until
1974 when autregan became part of
Trafford and it has hosted many events
and ceremonies over the years it was
extensively refurbished in 2006 to
create three ground floor rooms suitable
for meetings of up to 20 each or 60 if
configured into one
to intricately charge carved wooden
lions and a staircase lead up to its
jewel in the crown its Splendid chamber
room on the first floor with its
beautiful stained glass windows hosts up
to 70 and is now a wedding venue of
choice especially for those with limited
funds or a historic interest in the town
it is quite simply an Irreplaceable
Community Asset
we did meet your commercial Digger
bidder to explore possibilities for
joint use of the facility but this came
to nothing
their plan was to turn the chamber into
a permanent children's play area which
we and our supporters considered to be
shamefully disrespectful of the building
and its history
when people first hear of this their
answer is always the same but they'd
ruin it
also the sound of children playing
transmits easily from one room to
another and makes it impractical to hold
meetings at the same time
covenants in the lease would be
pointless and it was made clear to us
there would be no Community use at all
not even in the evenings or at weekends
we just cannot believe the council would
allow this to happen it would be a
travesty
this presentation should not have been
so much about procedural issues the real
problem is that the council has shown it
to be ambivalent about history and
Heritage that it is willing to sacrifice
these on the altar of the money God
that's what comes across the public do
not agree with you
I will finish with an appropriate quote
from the council's website e-petitions
were part of the count our part of the
council's ongoing commitment to
listening to and acting on the views of
the public I politely request the
council to do exactly that thank you for
listening
thank you Mr Stone
so we move on to responses from each of
the parties and the first response from
the labor group I believe is to come
from councilor Patel thank you
thank you Mr stone for bringing this
petition I would like to acknowledge the
genuine and heartfelt Community interest
in this matter
I will open my response by setting the
budgetary scene since 2010 traffic
Council has lost over 200 million pounds
from its budget that's 60p in every
pound significant Cuts have been made
since to non-statutary services from the
closure of our sure start Network to
Neighborhood libraries public toilets to
reductions in services that have
impacted on our parks and highways these
Cuts have left their mark on many
communities in Trafford we continue to
face tremendous pressures this year we
have closed a 26 million pound budget
Gap in face a further 6 million gap next
year when facing difficult budget
decisions as an Administration we always
seek to protect Frontline services and
our most vulnerable
the council has a number of estate
assets which we run at Cost Altrincham
town hall is one and is comparatively
expensive costing the council annually
around 60 000 pounds in order to protect
the important this important part of our
heritage we have to determine a
sustainable financial future for it
Ultram Town Hall was listed for disposal
in February 22 it was never considered
for outright sale but via release and I
would clarify therefore the Ultram town
hall is not being flogged off
redeveloped for flats or lost to council
ownership as an asset of community value
the council is legally bound to follow a
strict process around any potential
lease of the building and I wish to set
out the work that Council has undertaken
in February 22 the council issued a
formal notification of intention to sell
triggering a six-week period where
parties could log their interest in
taking over the town hall a further six
months were provided to allow groups to
prepare a business case for their
sustainable occupation of the building
during these six months meetings were
held and information requested and
shared between the council and three
interested parties who later submitted
bids in terms of the legal obligations
just concerning the disposal of an asset
of community value the council has fully
complied
I consider therefore that we have given
Community groups a fair and transparent
chance to bring forward their proposals
unlike George Carnell or Stratford
public hall two of the three business
cases received were Reliant upon ongoing
Council funding effectively meaning the
council lose control of the operation of
the building but retain Associated costs
the ask here of this petition is that we
now dismiss the legally sound process we
have undertaken and hold out
indefinitely until a sustainable
community business case emerges but to
do that presents the council with an
ongoing Financial Risk and exposure
I can paint a very positive picture of
council investment into Community
spacing Ultraman and surrounding areas
ultringham has a new library set within
a new wellbeing Center contrary to the
petition simply does in fact have a new
library not a closed one the council has
supported Community aspirations to
maintain a temporary library in hail
enabling its relocation to a new build
community center by acting as a funder
of this project a decision made by an
investment management board on
regeneration grounds the council has
invested significantly in Ultraman
Community Hub as part of our wider Hub
Network this most certainly isn't a
picture of disinvestment or decline
in conclusion following due process the
council intends to progress to the next
stage of the asset of community value
disposal which is to present the results
of bids received to the executive
committee and to seek a formal decision
on the successful bid for the reasons I
have set out I don't consider that we
should delay progression of this matter
Beyond February 23. thank you
foreign
thank you Mr Mayor
and thank you to to Mr stone for a very
good speech and an important alteringham
side of this story
I understand the council's desire to
save on costs but there are more ways
than the blunt commercial route that is
being plowed at present
a better route is available
one which seeks to reduce the current
cost to nil
perhaps considering
acceptable on a tapered Financial basis
all the while placing the responsibility
for the running of the building into
Community hands
that is what is needed here it delivers
cash savings but it also yields an added
value
added value of retaining the running of
the property fully in community hands
a community group will invest for the
long term
investing more than cash there will be
pride and ambition too
and there will be a care that is
unlikely in a commercial contract where
dilapidations are simply a matter of
course
dilapidations to the council chamber may
be catastrophic
further a community group
can apply for Grants
grants which are meant for such projects
such purposes
and there is an ongoing scope for that
to support such a project
retaining the premises for Community use
will be a good longer term Prospect for
the council
whereas a commercial deal likely needs
re-running several years hence
commercial operators will have no
loyalty to alteringham town hall Auto
Trafford Council
whereas a community group will because a
community group is self-renewing and a
better Prospect for the long term
the parallels drawn
in the in the petition wording with
Stratford public hall
and George Carnell Leisure Center are
relevant
and in treating Altrincham Town Hall
similarly balances it balances out the
community approach across the borough
it does this Council and the new leader
no favors to ignore a strong Community
bid for about for a building that was
after all built by the community for the
community thank you Mr Mayor
thank you councilor wetton do we have a
speaker to respond on behalf of the
liberal Democrat group
thank you
Mr Mayor thank you for this opportunity
to respond to this petition I'd like to
start by thanking Mr stone for
presenting the petition and congratulate
him on the extraordinary local support
it has gained
councilors perhaps they should declare
an interest I have lived close to or in
alteringham all of my life
it is a town with history and one of its
key assets and I would argue one of
Trafford Civic assets assets of note is
Ultram Town Hall
as you all know it is one of the three
Civic centers along with sale and
stretford that combined in 1974 to form
this very Council
the building has been in Civic use for
170 years
since the information since the
formation of Trafford Council Altrincham
Town Hall's fine Council chamber with
its impressive stained glass windows
have been host to countless weddings
meetings debates hostings and youth
theater groups indeed it was my personal
choice to be the venue for my wedding in
2019. alas my in-laws are from Cumbria
so of course and not for the last time
we compromised and we were married at my
wife's venue
apart from its Grandeur it should also
be noted that this has a registered
Memorial to those lost in the Great War
and displays the letter from King George
declaring Chapel Street in Altrincham as
the bravest in the land
Ultram town halls located as it is
adjoining to Ultraman Market
Hall located as it is adjoining to
Ultram Market if advertised and promoted
professionally could easily play a key
role in the continued success of this
Heritage quarter
it has considerable potential to add
value without losing its Community role
the liberal Democrat group is supporting
the sentiments and motivations of this
petition if not the exact wording it
would be wrong to lose this site's Civic
function and Public Access indeed
Trafford council's own motto demands
that we hold fast to that which is good
it almost feel as if it was written for
such a situation in mind
and I would also like to touch on a
matter of fairness as you all know
Stratford town hall is now successfully
run and managed by residence group
they were given time and support to
formulate their bid
this has resulted in that fine Town Hall
staying in the public domain
I'm aware there is a group led by
members of Ultram Civic society that
wishes to submit such a bid for auction
Town Hall
a bid that would lift the liability on
the council for this building
I'm asking the executive give Ultram
Town Hall as Fair a chance as it did
Stratford anything else would be
wrong-headed thank you Mr map
thank you councilor newgrash and I
understand that the speaker from the
green party will be councilor Welton
thank you
have you got your mic on Michael
thank you mayor and thank you uh to Mr
Stone
um and to everyone who signed this uh
petition which does demonstrate that
there is deep public support for keeping
the town hall available for Community
use and the green group including the
three alteringham Ward councilors share
that ambition
the building is both a Heritage asset
and a unique venue it should be a jewel
in the crown of a town that has been
frequently voted one of the best places
to live in the UK
sadly the town hall has been isolated
from the turnaround it has that has been
achieved across much of the rest of
Ultram town center and it is languished
under the management of one Trafford Amy
barely marketed its contact details
buried away on a gray internet page that
features not one picture of the venue
inside or out
this lack of marketing has been mirrored
by a lack of investment to overcome the
current limitations of the building as a
venue or to preserve and improve its
fabric investments in Wi-Fi are catering
standard kitchen and Energy Efficiency
improvements would have all served to
make the town hall a more viable venue
in the long term
we can understand why these Investments
haven't been made in an era of austerity
with more pressing priorities elsewhere
we understand why the council is Keen to
start negotiations with a private
business for a 25-year lease that will
cut the council's losses however it
seems a huge shame given that the case
for the town hall being unviable as a
public venue remains so unproven
we have Community groups interested in
running the town hall and keeping it
available for public use they see the
potential in the building they haven't
given up on it it would be wise for the
council to continue to nurture this
interest rather than rejecting it out of
hand as seems to have happened in the
autumn
with the following wind of this huge
petition and growing Community interest
there is potential for a community bid
to run the town hall
but this these things do take time as
councilman said to develop as we have
seen at Stratford public call and George
Connell
we therefore urge the administration to
have patience and not rush to relieve
itself of the burden it clearly sees the
town hall to be
allow time for those who see it as an
asset to come up with a proposal that
will allow our town hall to take its
place at the heart of our community
where a town hall should be
thank you councilor
Welton so finally will the leader of the
council summarize what will now happen
with this petition thank you councilor
Ross thank you mayor and clearly
um there have been some very passionate
contributions this evening I'd also like
to thank Mr stone for his introduction
of this petition
um
I am someone who knows Ultram Town Hall
I have been there several times I can
see the beauty of the building inside
and outside including the wonderful
windows and the stair features they are
not going the building isn't going
anywhere the council will still own the
building we are looking to lease it for
25 years so that we can Safeguard it
hopefully for another 120 years
we followed a process I have had very
strong assurances that the process was
carried out fairly
I am sorry to the other bidders that it
didn't work out for them but we
everything was done with due diligence
and above board I do hear the concerns
that Mr Stone has raised and I am very
willing before the executive come to a
decision in February to ask again and
stress test everything that you have
said to make sure that the advice we've
been given is water tight
councilor Patel very eloquently set out
the case for proceeding and also the
contexts that we face as a Borough I've
won over the past three or four years
now have been seeing and managing the
budget process and we are talking of
tens of millions of pounds every year
that we have to bridge as part of that
process and I have a duty as we all have
a duty to make sure that we do the best
for our residents of Trafford as a whole
and that is what this labor
Administration will continue to do this
is not an easy decision
and given what I've just said about
having further reassurances about the
process it will be one that's not taken
lightly but we do have a duty to protect
the council taxpayer and make sure we
put as every penny possible into
Frontline Services which is what we're
looking to do so I am very grateful to
the petitioner for coming I am I'm
delighted to see such an interest in the
building the building will remain in
Altrincham it will be there and I do
hope in a few years time that we'll get
over the austerity and have properly
funded local governments again and see
it as a valued as resource in the
meantime the reference to Stratford
public hall
um not the town hall as you said
councilor new grass Stratford Public Law
I was obviously as a ward councilor very
much involved in that and they went
through a process but they were
successful they had a robust case and
that is why they were rewarded the um
the uh the building and have done
wonders since unfortunately in this
despite the best efforts of the
community it has just not worked out
this time
but we do have another bidder which
we'll be looking to consider its
executive and that is where we'll be
taking this uh this decision so thank
you to everyone from your contributions
and uh thank you to Mr Stone once again
we will pick up on the concerns you
raised and we'll make sure that we have
assurances before we take any further
decision
thank you councilor Ross and I think we
note your comments with regard to what
will happen be Twix now and that
executive meeting
um that concludes the business of the
petition
um those of you who are in the public
Gallery who wish to leave perhaps you
might wish to do so now you're quite
welcome to stay but it might be
opportune to just take a very short
break whilst those who do want to leave
foreign
we're going to be here for about another
hour and a half
thank you
all right okay I think we're probably
about ready to continue with tonight's
agenda so item five
corporate health and safety report
I've now got item six it matters not on
my it's a six-month corporate Report on
health and safety and I invite councilor
Slater as a responsible executive member
to introduce the report thank you thank
you I just want to give a quick overview
of the report and explain that it
provides key health and safety
performance information and activities
under the health and safety units worker
with Partners over the last six months
it outlines initiatives delivered with
Partners to support our Workforce under
the Epic U and health and wellbeing
strategy there are a few key highlights
in the report that I'd like to share
with you and the product product sorry
I'll try that word again it's getting
stuck on my tongue proactive Audits and
support and it's top we've been looking
at Safeguard safe safer reintegration of
Staff into our offices over the last um
to 18 months and but obviously it's
since April 22 there has been a much
bigger return of our staff we've looked
at how we manage multi-disciplinary
operations and for staff coming back to
the town hall we've looked at restricted
space in our lifts and enhanced cleaning
regimes and we've arranged we've made
arrangements for guidance in play in
workplaces and also for safe Works safer
workstations at home for staff who are
doing hybrid working
all and we've carried out audits on with
health and safety support and we've done
some audits with uh one Trafford and
also with the
um bereavement services and our schools
and we've done
um work around safer delivery of our
elections and I know that our staff are
going to have a big piece of work to do
when they deliver the elections and this
may because there are so many changes
and that will be being brought forward
so
um that's just to remind you that health
and safety have to be involved in that
as well we want to refocus on
Arrangements by managing volatile
incidents within within our main Council
buildings also
um
just wanted to say that we've had a look
at
um our service level arrangements with
schools and we've delivered 77 delivered
77 of these and out of the 80 schools
that have purchased their service level
arrangements from was we've delivered
thorough Audits and fire risk
assessments and we've also given General
health and safety advice to these
schools and the health would win health
and well-being with collaboratively
delivered a range of health and
well-being activities opportunities to
the workforce and that is that is table
in table four of um the paper that's
been provided
uh we had a quick look at the accident
analysis and that we can see that there
hasn't been an increase in um in
incidents in relation to our staff this
year and the last year we had 63
incidents and this year has been an
increase to 68. we are taking a strong
look at violence and aggression and
physical assaults of our staff and these
are you tend to be in adult social care
special schools transport Provisions
when we're managing um challenging
behavior and also where our staff meet
face to face with them residents just a
few points to note no reporting of any
significant manual handling injuries
during this this period and there have
been no reportable
um riddle incidents to the health and
safety executive
and just a further conclusion we've
looked at a range of health and safety
and wellbeing
we've now refreshed the focus on
providing on the Audits and supports to
other services and we've prepared for
the launch of the new health and safety
initiative which has actually just gone
live and you'll see the link in the um
paper to your safety or well-being and
there's further details and updates will
be provided to the chamber
um in six months time thank you
thank you councilor Slater do any
members wish to speak on this report
in particular in which case the report
is for information can it therefore be
noted
thank you
item
uh
back a stage I think
right at this point in the meeting I
proposed to vary the order of business
to enable the council to consider the
Civic quarter area action plan which was
recommended to council by the executive
on Monday evening the relevant report
was issued to members as a supplementary
item of business last week
so it is item seven slightly out of
order a Civic quarter aerial action plan
um
as I mentioned the executives refer this
matter to council for formal adoption
and I would like to invite councilor
Patel the executive member for economy
and regeneration to introduce and move
the recommendation councilor Patel thank
you
thank you mayor
I was expecting to go at the end with
this I'm a bit confused do accept my
humble apologies but I'm just working to
a script as I perhaps you realize
I'm very pleased to present this report
to council following approval by
executive this marks the final stage in
the adoption of the Civic quarter area
action plan this plan demonstrates that
traffic Council recognizes and values
the importance of strategic planning by
investing in the planning process we get
on the front foot helping to positively
guide and shape the development of our
Borough the Civic quarter hosts large
numbers of visitors to Trafford
including those to Lancashire Cricket
Club it's home to existing communities
and has a number of Key Community
facilities including this town hall
traffic College UA 92 Stratford police
station and Stratford Leisure Center
the plan presents a robust framework on
which planning applications will be
determined providing a long-term Vision
which we will bring forward in
partnership with landowners developers
and infrastructure providers
the report and Associated papers set out
in further policies and I appreciate
there is a considerable amount of
information here
but I wanted to draw out some key
headlines the Civic quarter area action
plan will see the delivery of the
transformation of 20 hectares of
Brownfield land alongside the delivery
of quality green spaces up to 4 000 new
high quality homes within distinctive
neighborhoods potential for 50 000
square meters of new office and
commercial space with Associated
employment the creation of a
processional and well-being route which
will enhance the setting of our heritage
buildings and make Trafford a fantastic
visitor destination with better
connections to Stratford Town Center
Manchester and Salford critically this
plan will provide the council with a
mechanism to raise and coordinate
developer contributions to fund future
Community infrastructure
the Civic area core area action plan is
the first of several key strategic
planning documents that we're bringing
forward we will see the Trafford design
guide and code come forward this year
work has begun on the war side master
plan in partnership with Manchester
United peel and Salford the public
examination of places for everyone is
progressing positively and critically
the adoption of places for everyone will
support the emergence of our local plan
finally I'd like to thank residents
businesses and developers who have
contributed to this process and offer a
particular thanks to officers typically
in strategic planning terms this process
has taken some years to conclude and has
been the subject of several rounds of
public consultation reports to Executive
Council and a statutory public
examination phase I have seen through
this process how dedicated our offices
are and how they are driven by a genuine
desire to make this Borough a better
place this piece of work
is this is a piece of work that officers
and we as members should be very proud
of thank you
thank you councilor Patel is that
seconded please seconded mayor and
reserve the right to speak thank you do
any members wish
to speak on this report
councilor Morgan but
sorry you just raise your hands again so
that
right first of all councilor Morgan
thank you
uh thank you very much Mr Mayor um just
a few words really
um I'm really pleased to see this um
finally come to council indeed it was
the first meeting I had just after being
elected four years ago
um with the head of planning
um and um anyone who's read it will
recognize it's both an excellent though
huge piece of work and I'd just like to
thank
um all of the officers who have worked
so so hard on it and as well of all the
other
um plans that um that Council Patel has
mentioned
um from the conservative group and we'll
be supporting it tonight thank you
thank you councilman Morgan councilor
but
yes Mr Mayor I also uh would like to
concur with the councilor Morgan has
just said I just good good to see that
the inspectorate was able to go through
the plans in a thorough way and picked
out one of two weaknesses there were one
of them particularly being that there
wasn't as much recognition of the
Lancashire County Cricket Club so it's
been seen as a private members Club
initially uh but it's such a significant
and important aspect from amongst all
other things which contribute hugely to
the local economy and also provide
training and academy uh training to
Local Schools so thank you Mr May thank
you councilor councilor Ennis
thank you Mr American I um just welcome
the comments that have been made so far
can I ask counselor Patel uh when the
proposals for office space were
developed and have they taken account of
the post-pandemic drop in demand for
office space thank you
perhaps councilor Patel after that when
we've had the final personality to speak
or do you want to chip in now counselor
Patel
uh just briefly and I can get more
information on this I mean the plan was
started in in 2019 and yes it was paused
for covid and Revisited and those office
allocations were robustly examined
during the public examination
thank you councilor Jed Carter thank you
from the plans
I think taking in conjunction with the
Stratford Center investment plans it
shows excellent prospects for part of
Trafford that deserves investment I
commend the Council on the leadership
for this work thank you
thank you I'm not aware of any other
people wishing to speak in which case
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please
thank you we moved to item six now back
to six motions and there are six motions
that have been listed on the summons in
in the order in which they've received
may I remind members I think I've
reminded everyone earlier in the day to
get through the business and give
everyone who wishes to speak an
opportunity it may be necessary to limit
the time for speeches therefore please
can everyone keep their comments concise
and to the point and to avoid repetition
of points already being made thank you
so motion 6A preceding then with the
first motion regarding improving Public
Safety with later running trams I've
received notice that councilor frass is
to move this please thank you
thank you Mr Mayor this is a
straightforward motion calling for a
trial of late night trams on the
alteringham line
but the potential benefits of our motion
are hopefully far-reaching people
traveling home will feel safer than
nighttime economy will be more
prosperous and we can cut carbon
emissions while we're at it
the leveling up slogan is being reheated
again this month by the latest prime
minister but if leveling up ever meant
anything beyond a political slogan then
concrete steps like proper late night
transport must become a reality
it's the norm in big cities around the
world Stockholm Berlin London all have
late night transport there's absolutely
no reason why greater Manchester should
be any different
I've always believed the most highly
developed economies in the world are not
the ones where everyone owns a car but
the ones where public transport is so
good that everyone wants to use it
however this Friday I've just checked
online the last tram out of Manchester
through our Borough to ulti station will
leave Piccadilly at five to midnight now
let's be honest an 11 30 cut off to leg
it back to the trams is hardly a proper
night out for most young people and nor
should it be we all talk about a
thriving nighttime economy but each
night there are people with one eye on
the clock who dash off for the last tram
before midnight we should also think of
the people who work in the nighttime
economy
late night work can become unviable if
expensive taxis home are eating into
people's wages just as the cost of
living bytes
if the last tram has long since been and
gone then the only option for some will
either be a long walk home in the early
hours or simply not to take that shift
at all
it will increasingly Force some of the
lowest paid workers to either sacrifice
their safety or their shifts I will add
late night tram service would also
contribute towards tackling violence
against women and girls and there will
be members in this chamber better place
than I to speak about the realities of
gender-based violence and the need to
tackle it
some people might have concerns about
the viability or the uptake of such a
service so I would ask them to look at
the airport line which does run later
due to the destination it serves and
it's often used as the last tram home
for many so to conclude Mr Mayor the lib
Dems are proposing this motion as a
common sense and practical step towards
some better public transport
thank you councilor for us thank you is
that motion seconded
yes it's seconded thank you councilor
minis thank you thank you
um so uh Michael my colleague Council
frass has spoken on the various reasons
why why we should have later running
trams and I'm going to focus on one of
the reasons because there are lots of
reasons
um my reason is that I'm going to be
focusing on is to improve the safety for
women traveling on the tram Network
I've used a tram to go to and from
Manchester for many reasons since I
moved to timperley 12 years ago and that
includes commuting commuting to work in
Manchester
when returning at night after an evening
out I've taken the last tram with a
friend or my husband but I've never done
it alone
there's a reason
the last tram is busy many of the people
tend to have had a fair few drinks and
there are group there are fair few
groups of men on there the safety risk
is simply not worth staying out for
longer
so I therefore leave earlier
having trams running later will spread
the mass Exodus out and remove the
unsafe hot spots we currently have it
will allow women to get a tram at
midnight or later without the fears of
the last tram
I urge all counselors to support this
motion thank you
thank you councilor minis uh are the
councilors who wish to speak on this
motion I know councilor
Jerome Blackburn Williams
thank you and said uh in that case first
of all councilor Jerome thank you
thank you chair
um we will be supporting this motion we
know the benefits that late running
tubes have in London it adds greatly to
the nighttime economy to people's
enjoyment and brings us nearer to what
other European cities do
however we are surprised that the
Trafford lib Dems haven't learned from
this same motion being voted down in
Manchester and amended the Salford
Council in Salford there was three weeks
of Engagement cross party that brought
forced a much stronger set of principles
and asks for instance we need to
recognize that tfgm and Metrolink are
fully funded by fairs whereas tfl
receives 30 subsidy from government and
this isn't really mentioned in in the
motion and I feel it should be
um funding is desperately needed from
the government as the as Council of
frost said this would be true leveling
up and it is desperately needed the
Salford Amendment also recognizes the
need for running buses in tandem also so
a greater number can enjoy late night
travel not just on the um Tram routes
themselves
it recommends the need for rolling out
so the Salford Amendment also recommends
the need for rolling out of a GMC safer
streets program as quickly as possible
so women and girls can travel safely on
the network but on our streets too but
there's also a role for licensing which
is missed safe home initiatives through
our licensing team that could
incorporate business owners helping
their staff to travel safely so they
become part of the solution too so we
will support this motion but we would
have hoped it would have been far more
expensive more collaborative and more
far-reaching thank you chair
thank you councilor Jerome councilor
Miss Blackburn
uh thank you Mr Mayor tram users enjoy
the Metrolink service for its rapid
Journeys and access to areas across
greater Manchester
Danny Vaughn who runs Metrolink has
stated that passenger numbers on a
weekday are 50 of pre-covered levels but
there have been encouraging growth at
weekends however he does expect a
shortfall soon of 40 million pounds we
do support more tram Journeys but
suggest that that should be focused on
early morning transportation for workers
who undertake shifts for instance that
when the managing director of Manchester
Airport spoke to us he raised the issue
of lack of an early morning service to
ringway those working in Trafford Park
would benefit from this too I believe
getting people to work is more important
than bringing home those who want to
spend their Recreation somewhere other
than where they live we will though
support this motion
thank you councilor Miss Blackburn uh
councilor Williams
and thank you Chad ashant speak a
significantly given the busy agenda this
evening but I did want to confirm that
the labor group are happy to accept the
motion moved by the liberal Democrat
group subject to it being undertaken to
ensure that there's a strong and
reassuring Financial case underpinning
the extension of the service and
councilor Jerome has spoken to that
concern and councilor Blackburn has also
indicated concerns around patronage of
the service following the lockdown so I
shall repeat the points that they've
made but I would say is one of trumpets
Representatives on the greater
Manchester transport committee I'd like
to reassure colleagues that my labor
colleagues on gmtc enjoy an unamicable
and productive working relationship with
liberal Democrat colleagues on the
committee and I'd be more than happy to
approach them regarding this issue in
light of tonight's motion thank you
chair thank you councilor Williams
councilor adshead
it just briefly uh obviously a lot of
things been said there I actually did
raise this point actually uh at a tfgm
meeting some time ago when we had a spot
with Annie Burnham uh because it did
occur to me at that point there and I
did say to him uh we Proclaim ourselves
across connotation as a 24-hour City but
you can't have a 24-hour City without a
24-hour transport system and and people
are pointing out people who work in the
industry in just case people are going
out and join themselves you can get
people stuck in the city center with no
way to get homework extra expensive
taxis so I think that's a that is a very
pertinent point and obviously Council
Batman's point about the airport is when
I was also going to mention uh people
working there actually have it's very
difficult for people across the corner
Basin we do not have a proper integrated
transport system process I know uh we're
doing really good uh across conversion
we're putting more service into it but I
think the problem comes is that uh we do
need the funding that has been mentioned
for that London has them so we get out
so I think it's gonna be very difficult
but I think I welcome the motion and I
think we it's something that we should
be doing looking at this much make it
much more wider and get out there people
will work late it's not just case people
work at the airport or in town people
just working across different in places
like traffic might have a late shift and
they cannot get home without the use of
a car we want to downgrade use to a car
and we really do need to improve public
transport so we get that then it's not
going to happen
thank you councilor I've said and I
think councilor Ross wanted a very quick
word
thank you Matt um Justin the spirit of
collaboration
um you'll note that part of this
amendment says that I will be writing to
Andy Burnham about this and hearing the
views that have come across not just
from my group who are supportive of this
motion but also from councilor Jerome
and from councilor Blackburn please do
feed in your views to me and we can put
together a letter that we can send off
in collaboration
thank you councilor Ross um councilor
frass in the absence of any other people
wanted to speak you have the right to
reply respond to what's been said by the
councilors
thank you Mr Mayor yeah I will keep my
comments brief I'm delighted that there
is such a level of cross-party support
and I would add that we are nothing if
not pragmatic and we would have
certainly welcomed some of the ideas
from the green party and may well have
supported that had they have submitted
an amendment uh to those words around
extending it to include things like
buses so we'd happily look at that in
the future if other such motions come
forth on that topic
um and I agree with some of the comments
as a councilor ads has just said about
24-hour cities and we will of course
contribute to the letter that councilor
Ross will work on we will make sure that
the liberal Democrat group feeds in on
that uh thank you very much thank you
councilor for us the the motion is as is
and I will now put it to the vote all
those in favor
anyone against
or abstaining
unanimous thank you very much moving to
motion 6 B is a motionless evening about
fairer funding for Trafford and is to be
moved by councilor Oxford please thank
you
thank you Trafford council is facing
enormous challenges as the cost of
living crisis deepened to NHS is in
collapse schools are struggling and the
climate crisis looms ever closer yet due
to an unfair system based on outdated
data we receive one of the lowest
funding settlements in the country
expect to do far more to keep essential
Services going with far less with our
resources stretched to the very limit we
still face a budget gap for 2024-26 of
at least 16 million pounds
the levels of austerity we're all
experiencing are both unfair and
unjustified austerity will not lead to
the infinite economic growth that Tories
are still naively promising Cuts in
public services have long-term economic
consequences
indeed in such a time of great crisis
it's vital that councils are offered the
financial resources required to set up
the Innovative forward-thinking
preventative measures we need rather
than being limited to acting in a
restrictive reactive fashion
this motion calls for our leader to
write to the Prime Minister asking for
an immediate review of the funding
formula in relation to the campaign
recently launched by the f-20 group
which we joined last year this is a
cross-party group of councils fighting
for the funding floor to be set at 90 of
our average core spending power and for
a temporary fix given to level up local
government Finance in the lowest funded
authorities if agreed Trafford would
receive an additional 5.7 million pounds
a year
none of us want to see our residents at
risk we shouldn't have to use our
valuable resources fighting for scraps
at the table please support this motion
thank you councilor Oxford
um I gathered that councilor Hartley is
to second the motion is that correct
it is second mayor I'd like to preserve
the right to speak to the end thank you
um
councilors wishing to speak on this
motion I have councilor Coggins already
and I've got councilor frass Morgan
foreign
okay I think I might add one councilor
Coggins please thank you
and as Queens we have started the
process of trying to make contact with
other Greens in the F20 group to see if
we can uh support the the work that the
council is doing now thank you
thank you councilor Coggins councilor
for us
thank you Mr Mayor it is a core belief
of liberals that power should be
exercised as close as possible to those
that it affects over the years the
liberal Democrats have had many a
campaign about being the party of local
government so the bleeding Drive of our
councils is something that I feel quite
strongly about analysis by The Institute
of government says that total revenue
for all authorities was just over 60
billion back in 2009 by 2020 that had
dropped to 50. if we dig a bit deeper we
discover that in o9 council tax made up
about 20 out of 60 billion a third with
two thirds coming from the central
government settlements nowadays council
tax makes up around about half of the
total on average across authorities with
the central Grant down from two-thirds
to a half
so ordinary families are paying a
greater proportion of the council
revenues but the total amount in the
coffers is less this allows for a
particularly Insidious form of
electioneering where the conservative
party can say your tax is going up but
the services are getting worse whereas
the truth is the Tories are cutting
Local Government funding so they can
Finance Tax giveaways
the liberal Democrats will be supporting
this motion thank you councilor frass
councilor Morgan
foreign
thank you very much Mr Mayor
um the overall Spirit of this motion is
fundamentally important to bring to
council and tonight we'll be supporting
um this motion from the labor group
um firstly the data used in the formula
is just not of scratch um using Census
Data from before I was doing my gcses
and the number of snow days either
before I was born or before I went to
school really is incredible
um I think there's there is always going
to be a difference in funding between
councils firstly
be honest we are a relatively affluent
Borough compared compared to many and
the demand on services will be less than
another less African Brewers and
secondly we are a more urban Borough and
the demands and services for from
um on services will be less than for
Rural Brewers but and and thirdly sorry
no um system will ever be perfect and
every government will put it data into a
into a formula to calculate this and
we'll never be spot up but there's a fun
basic level of services that any Council
has to deliver and the difference is
particularly between some of the
um every Borough and some of the London
boroughs compared to the rest of the
country are Stark and if we compare
Merton and then the last census data we
have the same level of no deprivation
um category at 53.9 their funding is a
third person more the statistics I was
able to get than ours and Richmond upon
Thames is 50 greater and even within
London the variance as I think are
pretty odd to say the least so Richmond
and upon Thames is funded as per person
a quarter more than Redbridge
um in summary Mr Mayor the current
system needs reform it needs a view and
we're happy to support this motion um
from the labor group calling on the
government to do that thank you thank
you councilor Morgan now before I go
back to uh councilor Hartley and
councilor Oxford are there anyone else
who wish to speak okay councilor
Ennis and giraffe and it's just about
pip Mr Council Jerome on that one so
councilor Ennis
thank you Mr Mayor um I fully support
this motion and trafford's role within
F20 but another person who should be
using his considerable influence to
Lobby the government for fair funding is
Sir gray and Brady I know it's not the
usual reactionary dog whistle kind of
issue that gets him indignant enough to
get talking to government ministers but
this is about the future of essential
services for Trafford uh who and
Trafford residents have been
shortchanged by an outdated and unfair
funding formula so we should support
motion tonight and perhaps if the
lobbying with the F20 group hasn't been
as successful as we might have liked so
far maybe it's time for traffic to play
more of a leading role within that group
thank you Mr Matt
I'll be very quick
um I think the government promised us a
fair funding review in 2016 and they've
been promising it pretty much every year
since then and I think in the letter
we've received back from our current F20
campaign
um again promises a fair funding review
um to be happening in the near future
but will we ever see it it's a disgrace
thanks Joe thank you councilor Jerome
should I go to councilor Hartley before
we go back to councilor actually do you
want to take up your right
oh sorry councilor wetton may I just say
a few words in response to a comment
that was made earlier
um just a few weeks ago under the
previous leader of the council
um there was a request for
um support to be given to the councils
part in the F20 campaign
and
um
I approached the Graham Brady on that
to find that the previous leader of the
council had also approached the Graham
Brady on that I am aware that sir Graham
Brady made representations to government
uh on on the F20 uh campaign and uh that
that is not all
um concluded yet not all of the
financial settlement is concluded yet so
there may be something still to come I
don't know about that but I do know that
sir Graham Brady made representations to
government about the type of funding uh
the the difference in funding uh in
which is illustrated by the F20 campaign
thank you councilor wetton for that
additional piece of information
councilor Hartley
thank you mayor I'm pleased to hear that
this motion will get cross-party support
that's really welcome and several
speakers have set out the case really
well as to why Trafford needs more
funding I hear what council Morgan said
that well it's easy to describe Trafford
as an affluent Borough I think a lot of
cancers in the room wouldn't necessarily
describe that that's their experience
and their residence
um yeah I turn a point and I take the
point that we were an urban boat but
nevertheless Kent um Trafford is still
one of the worst funded counters in the
country per head and that that's that's
what the data should put
um shows and and that is because of an
outdated um funding formula
um we've seen some recent cash
injections for social care and discharge
but you know frankly that is a drop in
the ocean compared to the 263 million
pounds of budget cuts that this Council
has had to close uh since since 2010.
and I suppose what I would say I mean
the conservatives don't recognize the
value of local government that much is
clear from their actions and what I'd
say is that councils are really the best
place not just to help our most
vulnerable residents but also to deliver
sustained economic development through
new housing regenerating our term
centers which we're seeing in Stratford
and investing in our infrastructure
that's not something that the
conservative government seemed to value
and of course we need the extra funding
to fund their corporate aims of reducing
Health inequalities supporting people
out of poverty and addressing our
climate crisis
so
as in previous years
um the governments have made suggestions
that core spending power has increased
by virtue of this announcement but again
that bakes in we've talked about this
before that bakes in the assumption that
council tax and the social care precept
Will Rise by the maximum uh possible and
counselor frass reflected this in in his
comments because what that means is that
the government expect residents going
through a cost of living crisis and
through an energy crisis to pick up the
bill for their mismanagement of the
economy whilst they can point the finger
at local councils for raising council
tax it's it's disingenuous and it's
misleading to the electorate and
you know I welcome what came to the wet
and said but I can recall in that debate
the previous lead of the council
councilor Western
um called on conservative members in
this chamber to publicly call on their
colleagues in government to properly
fund local councils in including
Trafford so you know I'm grateful to to
cancel the Western for making those
representations to segre and Brady but
he is not publicly calling for Trafford
to receive a fair share of council
funding and I've not seen any
conservative councils in this chamber
publicly called for that either so if
they are supporting this motion which is
very welcome then I look forward to them
calling for this publicly and standing
up for the residents that they should be
representing in Trafford which they're
failing to do it's time for the
conservatives to be transparent with
Trafford residents that the government
that they support has chronically
underfunded local government for the
last 12 years and that is why councilors
up and down the country have no choice
but to increase council tax to avoid the
debate that recently befell their at
Council and Trafford is one of the very
worst funded councils in the country so
the modest commitment that this motion
asks for would ensure that Trafford gets
its fair share and I hope that all
members in the chamber can publicly call
for government to properly fund uh local
government and councils like Trafford in
particular thank you thank you councilor
Hartley go to councilor Oxford who has
the right for final comment
um yeah just thank you for your support
and I really hope that the conservatives
will also Lobby for this to happen thank
you all right thank you Council Oxford I
think we've had enough debate on this
and uh the motion is as presented all
those in favor
any against any abstentions no it's
unanimous thank you move on to motion 6
C concerns Public Health funding and
preventative disease is to be moved by
councilor Shirley Proctor thank you
thank you Matt
why am I proposing this well simply it
makes sense
tobacco is the biggest cause of cancer
and premature death in the UK and it
costs our NHS 2.4 billion pounds every
year
the diseases its causes are preventable
and the cost to society is almost 17
billion a year through lost wages lost
production lost Services sickness
absence to name but a few
more than this though it's the cost to
families
their personal loss of income the stress
distress and pain seeing your loved ones
going through surgery
going through chemotherapy in the hope
it will eradicate their cancer
hmm
I and the other councilor Proctor have
lived through this firsthand with his
dad first having throat cancer when Kev
was 11.
he smoked unfiltered cigarettes for all
of his life
and then both of his parents died of
cancer when Kev was 22.
my first dad died of cancer when I was
13. my second dad dying 17 years ago all
were smokers
all were from working class families
we've both seen the impact of
chemotherapy and surgery on our families
the distress of each person going
through the treatment and the stress
stress it put on our whole families it's
really personal to us this motion
more than that though it's the impact on
society as a whole except it it isn't as
a whole the prevalence of smoking in
poorer households compared to better off
households is worrying Health
inequalities are already large smoking
massively adds to these inequalities
it's time the tobacco industry paid for
the harm it does
we've known since the early 1970s
that smoking is harmful yet the tobacco
industry continues to profit from this
harm
I fully support cancer research UK's
call for a smoke refund levied on the
tobacco industry and us that you do too
thank you
thank you councilor Proctor
um I got a counselor Harding is to
second the motion
thank you
thank you mayor
I'll be brief because for me I see this
motion as being not controversial and
something that I would hope everybody
would want to support
um hazy pubs and cigarette scented
restaurants are now thankfully I think
of the past on the 1st of July 2007 it
became illegal to smoke in any Pub
restaurant nightclub in most workplaces
and work Vehicles anywhere in the UK
when the then labor government brought
the smoking ban into legislation it was
and has been one of the biggest Public
Health interventions we have seen
directly after legislation more people
trying to quit smoking and more people
succeeded and research and the British
medical journal estimated that there
were 1 200 fewer Hospital admissions for
heart attacks in the year following the
ban improved air quality and fewer
smokers will have contributed to this
the smoking ban was part of a trend
towards
um demonormalization of smoking it has
really helped a shift in culture around
smoking
the government has a plan and an
ambition to be smoke-free by 2030 in
England and in practice being smoke-free
means for each five percent average for
smoking prevalence I applaud this
ambition and I really look forward to a
day when smoking really does become a
thing of the past but that takes us to
be proactive and to really put some
steps in place here in Trafford we can
be thankful that our smoking rates sit
at 4.9 percent which is lower than the
national average of 9.1 however we
cannot be complacent smoking rates are
higher in the low income groups tobacco
addiction and the loss of income it
causes can exacerbate and lock people
into poverty and tobacco further locks
children from low income backgrounds
into a cycle of inequality If you
experience smoking at home you're much
more likely to smoke as an adult
so even though small smoking rates have
fallen and more than one insect but more
than one in seven adults still smoke
and this is concentrated in
disadvantaged groups so to conclude
as councilor Shirley Proctor has said
what we really need to do is make the
tobacco industry pay and we are fully in
support of cancer researchers make the
polluter pay and um the big four tobacco
Nationals are responsible for over 95 of
UK tobacco sales and make around 1.5
billion in profit profiting from ill
health and inequality the evidence is
clear not just from the UK but from
other jurisdictions that smoking
prevalence only continues to decline
when Tobacco Control policies continue
to be updated invigorated and improved
and this is what this motion is calling
for we cannot or must not keep shifting
responsibility over to localities we
know that public health do a brilliant
job around smoking cessation but let's
be realistic funding to Public Health
has been declining over years
this motion calls for us to support the
work of cruc and Ash as they push for a
polluter pays model and to fund Public
Health adequately we in the labor group
support the government vision for smoke
2030 help us achieve it support the
motion thank you thank you councilor
Harding now I've got one speaker already
and I'll ask for others perhaps to speak
I'll just make the opportunity at the
moment that we're just about on time for
15 minutes per motion this has been
stated as being potentially
non-contentious I suspect that the
following three motions will be much
more contentious and might need more
debate because there are amendments as
well so I'll actually ask anyone
speaking to limit themselves absolutely
to the succinct nature of it so can you
just raise your hands again sorry
councilor Leicester
like burn wet and oh goodness
but um
right councilor Leicester
thank you mayor
um
glasses
um I strongly welcome this motion
um as somebody who works in palliative
care I've also seen firsthand the impact
of smoking at very close quarters but
also a shocking reports that the health
scrutiny meeting last week highlighted
the fact that cancer rates in Partington
are higher than average for equivalent
areas
so we're pleased to support action uh
being taken to impact on one of those
factors I.E smoking which impacts on the
the cancer rates however we wouldn't be
the green party if we didn't also
highlight the associated effect of air
quality on those cancer rates so
particulates in nitrogen dioxide from
transport emissions have risen on the
a56 as our own budget report indicates
we also need measures to reduce air
pollution and should not be investing
investing in an expensive new road
across Carrington Moss
thank you councilor Leicester moved to
counselor Miss Blackburn
Mr
um
all members of my
died with ischemic heart disease due to
cigarettes I gave up smoking 45 years
ago but at the time it was a choice
sometimes either between food or ciggies
it is imperative that young people are
encouraged to desist before the Habit is
one that can't be broken
we recognize smoking is an addiction and
for some it's almost impossible to stop
but we do support this this very um good
motion thank you thank you councilor
Miss Blackman councilman Minis
thank you mayor um just to say the
liberal Democrat group are of supported
the motion
um my parents
um owned a nightclub for many years and
those are days when people did smoke
indoors and my parents have been uh have
suffered for conditions due to it so
um absolutely in agreement thank you
thank you Council the minutes councilor
wetton
thank you Mr Matt uh yes word just a
word of support for this item including
the call for the charge on on the
tobacco companies
it never ceases to amaze me how anyone
actually affords cigarettes let alone
how they actually smoke them but they do
and I don't I just don't understand it
um but while I'm on my feet I wanted to
just add a further point because it is
it is relevant and and I think
um I'm writing saying that they're um
there's a pride in the health scrutiny
Committee in a recent meeting a very
recent committee meeting where we took a
look at the
um
outlying higher cancer rates
particularly in the in the Partington
area
we had a good examination of that and
that produced a number of ideas which
officers will take away but it did
include that there would be a pushing
for some more health checks and
screening in Partington
particularly focusing on that area
because of the disparity of the cancer
in in that area thank you Mr thank you
councilor wetton uh I think I'll take
one more speakers councilor Thomas thank
you thank you Mr Mayor as a smoker of 14
too many years
I welcome this motion I'm desperately
trying to give up colleagues on our side
of the bench are aware of issues I have
in my life at the moment
my family are extremely worried and we
as a smoker putting the price up of
cigarettes does not deter you from
smoking I can tell you that things need
to be put in place behind funded by
tobacco companies to help people with
themselves of an addiction thank you Mr
Smith thank you councilor Thomas and
councilor Shirley Proctor you have the
right to conclude a right to reply
thank you chair
thank you
thank you everybody from the absolute
bottom of my heart
right I think that concludes debate and
once again the motion is as presented uh
all those in favor
anybody against any abstentions one
abstention thank you motion is carried
motion 6D next motion regarding a
parking policy for clean air and the
climate crisis is to be moved by
councilor Jerome please
thank you chair
um unusually we welcome the labor
Amendment it does two things lastly it
asks the newly established task and
finish group on car dependency to look
at the parking policy as part of its
work which we think is a great way of
getting this underway
um sooner rather than later it does
remove the cpre from the motion which is
a shame but I feel that could be a
challenge for the task and finish group
to find if they want to use that
assessment tool alongside other ones to
um this motion is not really about car
dependency though it's about the climate
it's about clean air it's about making
our roads safer and fairer for all
Revenue created from parking can be
reused within our transport budget and
ring fence for bringing about the road
changes that could enable the move
towards more walking and cycling but
also our vision zero improvements which
we agreed to here
it's a political choice that we really
need to make
but this needs to be a just transition
which is fair for all and transport for
Scotland did produce some really
excellent figures on this and they think
the current status quo is unfair people
on the lowest incomes sixty percent of
those have no access to a car the
disabled younger and older people women
and certain ethnic groups are also less
likely to have a car we need a transport
system that works for all but if you
look at that conversely 71 of households
in the highest income brackets have
access to two or more cars so I could go
on producing more figures but you can
see the imbalance
so we need to make pollution pay
transport is 24 of our carbon emissions
in the UK there are over 32 million cars
on our roads and this is growing in
number but it's growing in size of
vehicle too
many experts are calling for a decrease
of car use by 20 by 2030 just to meet
our Net Zero Ambitions so we have to do
this
so thank you to councilor Oxford for
bringing forward the task and finish
group with the urgency needed
our green councilors will be working
with you and hopefully supporting you
and bringing good ideas alongside that
but the kind of things that we would
like to see in this task and finish
group our current payment meters and car
Parks um the contract is coming up for a
renewal this year maybe we could see a
supplier that offers emissions based on
a net zero Parking Solutions
um higher emission cars should be paying
more it's a cheap and easy thing to put
into place and why isn't Trafford really
already doing this
um protections on our emerging local
plan that will see Gardens protected
from being turned into driveways this is
becoming so prevalent
but the biggest beast in the room I
think it really the the working Place
parking Levy which has brought 83
million worth of revenue for Nottingham
Council since its ipsage Inception in
2005 and helped cut carbon emissions
there by 33 percent
we know there are barriers to putting in
a working parking place Levy not many
places have done it but let's understand
the barriers and let's see if we can
make this happen over time
but as a CPR assessment tool makes clear
there's a plethora of things we could be
doing
so I asked this Council to support this
amended motion and let's get on with
this urgent work thank you chair
all right thank you Council Jerome now
you seem to have sort of just jumped a
couple of fences before actually
reaching them I'm going to ask I'm going
to go completely off-piste here and ask
with monitoring officers permission can
I ask councilor Welton are you happy as
the seconder of this motion to accept at
this point the amendment which is
otherwise about to be put
I believe we are right thank you in that
case can I just move to councilor Oxford
whose Amendment it actually is
to speak in the way in which she
probably would wish to say a few words
okay for the reason for this amendment
is that our last scrutiny committee
meeting using due process it was agreed
to set up a task and finish group
looking at reducing car usage and
dependency
labor group are totally committed to
this issue for all the reasons outlined
in this Motion in an Ideal World Car
usage could be partial officer against
an integrated accessible public
transport system but while we waited for
Andy Burnham to realize this Vision as
chair of the task and finish group I'm
hoping we can come up with some creative
innovative ideas which will of course
include looking at our car parking
policy controls and enforcements
um have I seen a reason why we should
restrict ourselves to the London cpre
Benchmark policy tool which was designed
for use in London which does have a
public transport system that works but
I'm sure we can explore the useful ideas
contained in this tool in the scrutiny
process as well as looking at what other
accounts have adopted I'm very much
looking forward to working together in
this cross-party task and finish group
to tackle this very important and
contentious issue and all your
contributions would be very welcome
thank you thank you councilor Oxford so
councilor Patel are you second in the
amendment
seconded reserve the right right
um now does anybody wish to speak on the
amendment other than has already been
said
possibly not can we therefore have a
vote on the amendment all in favor this
involves a task in Finnish group being
set up Etc I think of which all members
are aware all in favor of the amendment
any against
extensions
fall right okay so we've now got an
amended motion
um
mm-hmm
do we still have further debate from any
member about the now amended motion
which is effectively now the substantive
motion
Council of frass council The Minis
you're gonna have to be brief if you
want to
councilor Morgan that order frass Menace
Morgan you've got about a minute each
maximum
cancel the first please thank you thank
you Mr Mayor we know that tackling the
climate crisis is the only way to secure
the long-term future of our planet so I
hope that others might be able to speak
to the law of unintended consequences
such as driving people away from local
shops and businesses served by our
Council car parks and into the arms of
large supermarkets with their free car
Parks which are further away lengthening
not reducing car Journeys I represent
many people for whom active travel is
sadly no longer an option and we do have
to take them into account
I shall restrict myself to a very brief
technical scrutiny at the meeting of the
scrutiny committee on the 30th of
November in this Municipal year I
believe it was councilor Welton who did
actually ask about the variegated
parking charges based on the size of
vehicles and he was told by the director
of place that Trafford has already
undertaken work to look at this but the
cost of expanding his Parking Department
to administer such a complex system of
charges would outweigh any revenue
generated
so during a cost of living crisis the
director also raised serious concerns
about the impact on less well-off
communities particularly in the north of
the borough
so yet the tool that we are being asked
to adopt in this motion sets out that
very idea
so I think councilor press now we've
actually we saw but we had a vote like
um we were abstaining weren't you yes
well perhaps you're abstain in the vote
that we're about to have I mean sorry if
we haven't in that case I will summarize
just to say that one sentence of ten
words if you would
I'll count them um no we're very pleased
that early emotions to support uh public
transport of Carrie but I feel there's
not enough carrot in this there's too
much stick in this motion okay right
thank you councilor Minis
thank you mayor I won't I won't be long
um when parking charges were about to be
introduced to timpley and I objected on
behalf of my elderly residents who
cannot walk to the village for shopping
we all want clean air I cycle walk use
public transport and now a household of
four shares the one car two drivers
um what this motion entire has missed is
the solution the solution is better
infrastructure for cycling and better
public transport and that's how you
encourage people to make the better
choices
um I would rather much more carrots than
the stick thank you all right thank you
Council The Minis councilor Morgan
thank you very much Mr Mayor I think the
vast majority of the members in the
chamber degree we need to reduce car use
and need to focus on Blue badge holders
and I really doubt there's anyone who's
um can stand pavement parking
particularly if any of us have had to
ever push primer or pushchair um I think
there's things I agreed with
counciladrome and as you can probably
imagine there's things I didn't agree
with them but I think there's one thing
I'd just like to highlight that you did
mention I think is really important it's
on car size
um I haven't got the data to hand but it
was something that I have seen on on
Twitter that the growth of Carl Wix is
quite incredible and it really does add
to the parking problems that we've all
highlighted and we all be supporting um
the substantiative motion right okay now
I know I've I understand so we're we're
just concluded where we are actually up
to is we actually have had the amendment
which has been carried uh and we want
very final word for any member before we
go back to councilor welcome before we
go back to the proposer of the original
motion councilor Jerome right councilor
welcome
thank you yeah I would urge members to
actually really read the toolkit and
look at the the very very wide range of
measures that are set out there it's
more of a menu it's less of a
prescription there are
measures there that could be applicable
for traffic there are others that
probably aren't but it really is a tool
for
helping us to develop a future worthy
parking policy so I really feel I do
feel that there's possibly a bit of
negativity that is based on maybe a lack
of reading and information into what the
tool the tool is and I would recommend
that people go and do have a look at it
and maybe you'll you will find some
ideas that really interest you you I'm
really looking forward to this scrutiny
committee with councilor Oxford and
thank you very much the administration
to allowing it to happen all right
councilor Jerome as the proposal of the
original motion which has now been
amended uh
and is the substantive motion you've got
the last word I'm sorry councilor Patel
and Oxford we've let Mr councilor Jerome
go with it thanks chair I'd just like to
thank everybody for the support and and
the good words
um so I'll leave it at that and let the
meeting move on thanks Jeff right so
that amended motion now substantive all
in favor
any against
abstentions
oh unanimous there we go right moving on
to our motion 6E can cancel a z move the
next motion regarding a youth Council
for climate change
thank you man during a recent school
visit May a year six student from Bowden
is worried about a climate crisis she
asked me about how she and her friends
can have their say on a response to the
crime emergency
it allows me to realize that young
people have been under represented and
their voice are largely missed in
traffic I believe young people are often
more vulnerable to The Climate crisis
than older adults than than older adults
who have better paid work more
qualifications at the capital and a
stronger Network
ignoring young people's concern causes
more anxiety about climate related
disruption hence we are calling the
traffic Council to create a youth
Council for climate change where young
people can speak up about their issues
that affect them and for adults to
listen and they and take their views
seriously I know and we all know the
climate crisis is an issue children and
young people are passionate about we
also know that youth leadership is
largely untapped resources for the
climate action
however youth leadership can mobilize
community at speed and at scale
therefore we believe it is vital for for
them to have their to have a platform
where the traffic Council can work with
them in a meaningful way on this
profound challenge
thank you councilor Z is that motion
seconded
seconded Mr and you're reserving the
right thank you councilor Miss Blackburn
I've received notice of an amendment to
this motion and I invite councilor Hines
to move this now please thank you thank
you mayor um and I am going to continue
this very strange night of broad
collaboration and agreement changing it
very very strange
um because
um
there is an amendment to this motion but
it is a friendly Amendment
um because it is an incredibly important
motion actually
um and we do agree that young people do
have a very powerful message in relation
to the climate crisis
um and we know that their future is
impacted by the decisions that are made
by our generation
and so we agree that the voice of young
people in influencing the decisions
taken in this borough is hugely valuable
and I did just want to briefly explain
um the changes that we've made to the
motion and why we do think that these
are important and the changes to the
first paragraph really are just to bring
the motion up to date because I believe
this was um due to be moved at the last
council meeting and that was arranged
which just followed um the Egypt car and
and then and we've we've changed
slightly
um paragraph four and this is to reflect
the council's positive intent to listen
to the voice of young people but we have
taken out the sentence that relates to
young people being more vulnerable
specifically to
um older than older adults because
obviously adults are in impacted by the
climate crisis and adults are vulnerable
too and so we've just taken out the
specific done older adults and but we
have still reflected
um that young people
um are often more vulnerable so so we've
left that in there and then the
remaining changes really to paragraphs
five and six are about Consulting with
young people to understand how they want
to engage with us and we do know that
there are lots of forums already where
young people do
um have the climate crisis as their
priority I know that um I believe that
is the case for trafford's youth cabinet
and school councils also have this very
high on their agenda and we want to try
and reach as broad a network of users as
possible we think that'd be very helpful
so understanding how young people want
to engage with us and the the form that
they want to do that through and that
might be very different than meeting
together in a council and type Forum so
and what we're proposing really is that
we do need to put together
um an appropriate mechanism so that
we're able to receive and understand
what those views are and that we are
then able to feed those into the policy
making and the decision making of the
council in that very meaningful way
um and as members will probably recall
from
um the last council meeting working with
our children and young people
um in Trafford is one of councilor
Ross's priorities as leader of the
council so we would very much look
forward to um to this piece of work so
that's that's how we uh we move this
amendment right thank you councilor
Hines thank you this I understand the
amendment is to be seconded by councilor
Oxford
yeah just briefly um clearly it's very
important that young people have a
strong voice in the climate crisis
dialogue
we've got a world of increasing
insecurities and climate anxiety or Eco
anxiety is yet another factor which
mental health practitioners recognize as
being linked to increasing mental health
issues amongst our young people
traffic Council committed to empowering
our young people but rather than the
motion suggestion of the grown-up
setting up a youth counts of climate
change the amendment suggest a far more
empowering option of enabling
facilitating our young people to decide
for themselves their own preferred
method of communication regard the
climate crisis we've got some great
examples of transformational youth
leadership Greta Thornburg Vanessa
berries Emma Greenwood and I'm really
looking forward to welcoming our first
Trafford youth leader thank you thank
you councilor Axford our council is
wishing to speak I know I've got
councilor Coggins already and they're
going to councilor Williams and we do
need to be Reef as you know councilor
Coggins
ocean and we're also happy to support
the labor Amendment it gives the
amendment gives the agency back to the
young people as we have heard and rather
than having the council organize them
without their input and as the
conservatives have been so Keen to have
the voices of young people heard in this
chamber I wanted to share a few comments
from the co-chair of the Young Greens
who I sent this motion to and in
reference to the low paid work mentioned
for young people he says it might be
worth reminding them that age-based pay
discrimination is the responsibility of
this party's government
and he also said that this motion is
quite instrumental in this presentation
of young people youth leadership isn't a
resource for people to use to their own
ends
and I think that speaks to the first
problem with this motion which we do
support as I say as a whole but there is
a hypocrisy in that it's doing the very
thing that it claims to try to avoid it
is using young people in a tokenistic
way
there's an even deeper hypocrisy when we
look at the fact that this tokenistic
Green motion is coming from the party
who is opening a new coal mine who is
incentivizing North Sea oil and gas
production and who's prime minister Who
currently speaking on the amendment not
on the motion by the way okay I
understood it was smoking in the motion
okay I will I will I will I will
summarize in total cancer Z said that
youth leadership can mobilize change at
great speed but you know what can
mobilize change even greater speed is
government leadership and genuinely
bringing young people's voices into
decision-making Chambers as I think the
labor Amendment seeks to do and
amplifying their voices is something we
wholeheartedly agree with an attempt to
weaponize Young people's climate passion
for the party running the most
incompetent climate wrecking government
we have seen risks being patronizing and
tokenistic greenwash thank you thank you
councilor Coggins Council Williams
thank you Jeff and I will try to be
brief I just wanted to um supplement
some of the points made by councilor
Heinz I'm explaining the purpose behind
the amendment because they're quite
frankly I fundamentally don't agree that
the voices of young people in Trafford
have been quote largely missed when it
comes to the climate emergency in fact I
think that young people in the Bubba
have been some of the most vocal and
persistent Advocates around the climate
emergency certainly I can think of the
sail west schools climate conference
which has been held this year and I'm
aware of the work that Trafford youth
cabinet have undertaken respect to the
climate emergency frankly I think it
would have been welcome if they had been
consulted before this motion was brought
before Council it's only right that we
recognize that the Western funders of in
respect to damage to the planet are
Generations that are gone and that young
people aging into adulthood today are
those burdened with trying to fix the
mess they're inheriting which is
something they're only too aware of
frankly if anybody needs a word it's
people such as Mishi sunak who very
nearly didn't even bother turning up to
cop this year something which is Frank
evidently overlooked in the motion now
I'll leave it there thank you very much
thank you Council Williams uh councilor
Minis
um just to say that we're supportive of
the Amendments which brings it more to
the young people the young people are
the future and have a lot to contribute
I know that my children certainly um you
know are very very much engaged uh we'll
and they're the ones that are going to
suffer the most so uh from damage to our
planet so that's as I said the amendment
makes it much better thank you thank you
councilor minis councilor Zee has the
right of reply to this amendment I'm
sorry
30 seconds councilor Miss Blackburn
thank
you and they're very aware of
environmental issues and I hope that
trafford's interaction with secondary
pupils is productive
and personally speaking I'm not a
hypocrite I was at cop 26 myself and I
am very aware and understand about
environmental issues so I think I'll
just leave it at that thank you thank
you councilor Miss Blackburn as I said
councilor Z you have the right to reply
with regard to the amendment thank you
mayor it is disappointing that the youth
Council for climate change is not
accepted as I said it is a significantly
vital for them to have the to have a
design a platform where they can share
their concerns and hold other
accountabilities on this issue I urge
the travel Council to take this motion
seriously and develop a meaningful and
consistent program in engaging with the
Youth and Young people thank you
councilor z i now put the amendment to
the vote then please all in favor of the
amendment
those against
abstentions
missing hands never mind I'm sure
gentlemen at the front will have
photographed them from afar the
amendment is carried so it becomes a
substantive motion and I think we
already had substantial discussion and I
propose without further debate to put a
move to a vote on what is now the
substantive motion so all those in favor
of that
thank you all those against
abstentions
none I'll take it as unanimous we move
to the final motion
motion 6f is with councilor Buck please
can you move the final motion concerning
Community engagement
thank you Mr Mayor neighborhood forums
previously took place in each Trafford
locality neighborhood forms met on an ad
hoc basis and what can mean for specific
topics they have also been used as
consultation vehicles for example as
part of the budget consultation
to local locality working locality
Partnerships were introduced which
partly took on the role of neighborhood
forums locality Partnerships with a
group of local Citizens Community groups
councilors and staff who worked in
organizations such as the council police
Leisure housing and health who came
together to share information and ideas
build relationships and create change
the locality Partnerships are no longer
meeting not undertaking any of the
functions that they were established for
Community engagement at the council is
currently primarily undertaken by the
community engagement team which
established undercovered 19 and is
funded until March 2023.
with discussions taking place regarding
how to secure the future of the team the
inclusive economic economy and
communities team also undertake some
Community engagement
but there's no scope within that team to
establish neighborhood forums the
executive member for cultural Leisure
and strategic Partnerships has
responsibility from reporting promoting
a neighborhood and area Focus across the
council and the borough and for ensuring
appropriate consultation with partners
and the community on matters within the
portfolio
the ruling labor group 2018 Manifesto on
page five promised I quote we will hold
quarterly public meetings with the
council executive at which members of
the public can attend and ask questions
and continue to explore better
communication Channels with the public
unquote these meetings do not appear to
be taking place currently
in 2021 Trafford labor Manifesto on page
16 stated regarding the climate
emergency that I quote the labor group
commits to convening a Trafford citizens
assembly in this calendar year to
involve and engage residents in the
decisions we need to make take to move
forward with our green agenda
emotion was passed at the December 2020
council meeting and part of the
resolution was to convene a citizen
assembly within 12 months to inform
decision making in this area and
increase resident engagement and
involvement in the fight against climate
change
it was announced that the October 2022
council meeting that the citizens
assembly will not be progressed however
the council believes that neighborhood
forums can provide an opportunity for
citizens to speak face to face with
counselors and Council officers they can
also provide an opportunity for citizens
to be consulted in their local
communities on new policy proposals with
the end of covid-19 lockdown direct
engagement between citizens and the
council can and should take place on a
more formalized basis as in the past
and the council resolves that the
executive member for cultural Leisure
and strategic Partnerships brings a
report to Executive no later than March
2023 executive meeting which sets out
the options for engaging directly with
citizens through a neighborhood Forum
approach
thank you councilor but I understand the
motion is to be seconded by councilor
Miss Blackburn
yeah sorry yeah Reserve this uh right to
speak thank you and I'm aware we also
have an amendment which has been
received in respect of the motion and I
invite councilor Harding to move the
amendment thank you
thank you mayor and thank you councilor
but for um your motion
um
I just want to mention a couple of
points really about how this
Administration is seeking to engage with
communities and residents so really
following on from the incredible
Community response during the global
pandemic and the Ukrainian Refugee
support program and the cost of living
crisis we have developed eight building
blocks for community-based working and
one of these sets out the aim to design
our services with local people at the
heart of what we're doing to meet their
needs and oversight six within the
Living Well in my community coordination
group
we've been producing neighborhood plans
we've been out to meet all of the
neighborhoods and elected members have
been invited to all of those sessions
with residents and providers and
voluntary groups and the hubs we have
undertaken an exploratory piece of work
with Partners to understand our Health
and Social care Arrangements what that
will look like now that ccgs are no
longer functioning and there's been a
whole restructure across Health and Care
eye chair boards and I look around the
room at some of those boards and I'm
really disappointed that those boards
don't truly represent the diverse nature
of our
um Borough really
and that's why when I chaired the age
World board I made sure that we invested
in community reporters as part of
talking about my generation and they
have been the eyes and ears of our
community for older people giving a true
representation of what it is like to age
in Trafford we have taken a much more
tailored approach with communities an
example being sail more and hail Place
plans which we're Consulting on at the
moment and such as the great piece of
work which is the Trafford poverty truth
Commission where we work alongside with
those with lived experience of poverty
to guide the policies and approaches
that we want to take forward
in how we deliver services to meet the
needs of our residents it's been an
incredible piece of work and I really
look forward to the recommendations that
will come out of that in March another
example is the women's voices work that
took place in December and that's aimed
at reducing inequalities and we had a
room at the Life Center full of women
from across Trafford contributing to
health policy
so the community you're right the
community engagement team is currently
under review and it's anticipated the
team will continue beyond March 2023
with a strong link into the neighborhood
program
so the proposed steps are there's going
to be a quarterly stronger communities
board kovid saw a change in how we run
Trafford partnership that's currently
under review and we welcome your
thoughts on that we had a really busy
vcfsc launch last week at Stratford
public hall there's a real commitment
and passion as to how we do things
across Trafford
I don't want to go backwards Council
abort where we see the same old faces
coming to meetings that don't really get
us anywhere I want to move to genuine
and meaningful Communications with our
residents it's a working progress but
I'm proud of the work of this labor
Administration so far and I rely on all
of you as Ward counselors to contribute
to that and interestingly enough I'm
just looking at a piece from 2011 when
it talks about the ruling group then
which I believe were the conservative
group where you were looking to get rid
of the neighborhood forums because they
weren't working in their current formats
so I'm a little confused that you
decided back then they weren't working
but now you want them back I'm just
looking to make sure that we engage with
our residents in a much more meaningful
way I'm happy with the building blocks
that we have in place I'm happy with
things like our track of property truth
permission and I'd be delighted if you
counselor bought and your colleagues got
on board with some of that work thank
you thank you councilor Harding the the
amendment is I gather as seconded by
councilor Walsh
thank you mayor and I'll reserve the
right to speak thank you who would wish
to speak on the amendment I gather that
councilor Jerome does who else
okay councilor Jerome off you go
thanks Jay
sorry
um it's not your apology I don't think
is it so thanks for the background music
um the main stumbling block to the
motion is the request for a report in
March 2023 just a quick conversation
with officers we'll tell you this is
unrealistic and will not produce a kind
of research and evidence that we need
for decision making in this Council
so I'm glad this amendment has addressed
this it really you know when we do
motions we should be speaking to
officers
um during covert we did see the council
adapt its approach and direct its effort
and resource towards the community hubs
this has been a great success in
Partnership working the hubs are expert
in listening advising supporting and
directing residents to the help they
need they're entwined in their
communities have adapted from covid to
the cost of living crisis and the green
party would like to thank all those
involved especially the tireless
Volunteers in the community hubs and one
thing I want to mention is Alfred brow
does have a locality partnership which
is um run by the the brilliant and Paul
Huxley of ground force G-Force G4 sorry
uh apologies and um it is a well
attended by local Altrincham councilors
and it's achieved a lot in its time it's
produced great results and it does bring
the council the police tht and other
partners together in its decision making
but it does really need strong residents
running it and I'm just wondering
whether that can be replicated across
the borough and whether the council can
really take responsible if we're to
finish on time I think we just quickly
wanted to say we can't support the
amendment
um okay thank you
sorry councilor we we will not finish on
time if we continue you've just stated
you're not going to support the
amendment that's fine can we go to
council the new girl please complete
that promises
they should take they should take credit
to them
thank you councilor new gosh very long
either thank you I I must say I am
actually a little confused
and
I will say why because like Oldfield
brow we have the highly successful
broomwood partnership
um the leader of the uh conservative
group has been invited to every single
meeting since she was elected and turned
up once
um I looked up the things it was uh
she may have been very busy on the
libdam group and I attended every single
one
um and I have done everyone that that is
why I'm a little bit confused by it we
have them they are extremely successful
they do bring people together and they
give
the local voice and and investment in an
area when used properly thank you for
that information Council your new gross
counselor Acton
I didn't know whether you said that
Oxford or action act on sorry
yeah you're down to 30 seconds now as
well
apart from what councilor Harding said
and she listed everything really that
that is is happening we also opened up
this Council where every committee now
has public questions where residents can
participate within that committee uh we
we opened up
this Council chamber
where questions can be asked and are
asked
probably every single meeting we lowered
the number of signatures needed to
actually raise an issue in this Council
chain but as we saw tonight that never
happened under the tourists but we've
made it happen and I think that is you
know what
we actually believe in the community and
not like the Tories who just pretend to
thank you councilor action councilor
Miss Blackburn
thank you councilor Miss Blackburn uh
the family speaks right with this is the
amendment from the uh councilor
fine
who was who proposed it
um
sorry
I've got to say councilor Harding right
can we just go back to councilor Harding
to
speak at the end of the debate on the
amendment thank you
right thank you in that case I see I'm
councilor Walsh 30 seconds
can you stand by the microphone please
they were a great success
and the conservative group got rid of
them that's how much they leave in that
then they didn't believe in it in all
those years ago councilor Hardy said but
now they've changed their mind and I
think there's a there's an Amnesia
cropping in up up in the conservative
party
we can't remember when we had a party
right we can't remember thank you
I can't remember
thank you every
excuse me the chamber is not the place
for a Realms of Applause thank you
so Mr councilor Freeman oh dear or not
councilor Harding has concluded the
debate on this can we go to a vote
please on the amendment all those in
favor
all those against the amendment we've
got one two three four seven eight
Council administer again eight against
the amendment is the amendment is
carried
um I think we've had quite enough debate
about it it's
I think we all know where we are in
terms of what we really want underlying
this at the end of the day I think we
all want more engagement so can we just
therefore go straight to a vote on the
amended motion which is now the
substantive motion all those in favor
all those against
abstentions unanimous thank you very
much indeed right I can go to the last
page now all right and I've got 30
seconds as well so that's the end of the
meeting I thank you all for your
attendance I extend a general invitation
and to use councilor heinzwords a
friendly invitation to join me in the
Parlor for refreshment if you wish and I
hope you enjoy the rest of your evening
thank you